there's a lot of similarities i think
between your personal philosophy and
jordan peterson's i know you've spoken
to him a couple of times what have you
learned from him
well the the most interesting thing that
i learned from jordan peterson and i
mentioned this the first time he came on
my podcast was that
you know he's a trained academic that
studied this stuff his whole life and
we came to a lot of the same conclusions
about things and i just came to those
conclusions through
living and the the experiences that i
had and he came to them through studying
this stuff in a very rigorous way
and and the cool thing is luckily for me
i had written books that sort of
predated uh i got there first yeah i got
that first it wasn't that i got there
first but
i mean
this these were the thoughts that i had
i mean discipline equals freedom that
book came out i think before i before
jordan peterson was on the scene it's
the book extreme ownership which is
about taking personal responsibility
what's about taking responsibility and
you can definitely apply it to personal
responsibility
so luckily for me those books kind of
predated uh jordan peterson
coming onto the scene and
and doing everything that he did but
again it's not like i created any of
those things it's not like i created it
before he created and it's not like he
created it before
other philosophers had figured these
things out
so
i'd say the most interesting thing about
jordan peterson that i that i found and
i think it was pretty interesting to him
too was the fact that we both had kind
of come to these same conclusions and we
had lived very different lives i mean
i'm sure there's
more disparate lives that we could live
but they're pretty different lives
and
that's that was a very interesting thing
and it made me feel like
well it made me feel good about the fact
that the things that i had figured out
were in line with things that he had
figured out and that means maybe there's
a little bit more strength and
universality to these things that i
believed which
which felt pretty good
just gonna pause that do you wanna go
and see if there's someone stealing
things outside
if there's someone stealing things can
you let me know
it looks like they're bringing things in
that's the opposite
it's nice to know or to think that
something that's been proven in the
field of battle or on the field of play
is backed up in academia right that
someone can go through the annals of
philosophy history and come to a similar
conclusion as you yeah uh absolutely and
you know the stuff this stuff that i say
is in the bible the stuff that i say is
in stoicism and and
jordan peterson you know says the stuff
that i say or i say the stuff that he
says again i'm not trying to compete
with jordan peterson on any level
uh especially some kind of an
intellectual level but
we have
similar thoughts about things and that
predated either one of us knowing who
each other were so i think that's pretty
cool
why do you think people are drawn to
advice that's telling them to do hard
things
kind of seems counterintuitive
why do i think people are drawn to
advice telling them to do hard things
because i think p any
person any human realizes that if you
want some kind of a good outcome you're
going to have to work hard for it
and if you and if you don't work hard
for something you're not going to get an
outcome that's really worth much
well that is
the thing that separates the
achievements on the other side of it
right
if it was easy everyone would do it if
it was easy everyone would achieve it so
this is one of the things that i i try
and rely on
when training's been getting hard i
ruptured my achilles a couple of years
ago that sucked i wouldn't advise it as
an injury generally yeah and it's like a
random
you know a lot of times people just do
it you know getting out of their car or
something i was playing cricket the most
british way to snap into a very british
way to snap your achilles for sure um
[Music]
during that during the rehab for that
it's pretty just uncomfortable it's
endless calf raises right which not fun
and
the discomfort that you feel and the the
pain the um fear of it re-rupturing
which is the number one thing you're
doing it to have happen the thing that i
went back to in my mind was this is why
i'm here the discomfort that i was
feeling the um
effort the pain the sweat thankfully
this was during covid so it meant that
if i had to do a workout every single
morning for half an hour on just my
carbs it's like what else are you doing
right there's a pandemic going on um
this is why you're here was the reminder
it's like look this is the reason why
the re-rupture rate is uh five to ten
percent because people don't want to do
this thing
people don't want to do the thing
because it hurts because it takes half
an hour every single day for nearly 12
months it's a full 12-month recovery
that's why this is why you're here and i
think that you're right i think that the
selection is
people deep down know that picking up
heavy things physically
psychologically existentially culturally
is good for us and i think that that's
why it's attractive
i agree
another thing that i think is that
it's one of the reasons why people can
become a little bit triggered triggered
they can become a little bit
uncomfortable when they see somebody
else that's got a lot of discipline
because i think deep down they know that
if they had that thing that that would
fix a lot of the problems that they have
in their life is this a dynamic that you
that you've seen
i'm sure that's a a bummer for someone
to look at someone else that's working
really hard and
and achieving some positive things and
they know that they're not maybe working
as hard as they could be and they're not
really achieving what they want to
achieve i'm sure that stings a little
bit
another thing that jordan said recently
is that the problem with twitter is that
the price of being a prick has fallen to
zero i feel like you'd agree with that
as well
yeah yeah i guess i'd agree with that if
you're gonna spend a bunch of time on
twitter you're gonna you're gonna run
into a bunch of people that don't like
you
and they're gonna say it and there's
nothing you can do about it so
and the ability for people's words and
the consequences of those words to
become detached as well is something
that's only pretty recent i mean i mean
i guess you could have
sent a mean telegram
a hundred years ago
yeah
i
i i would recommend that you don't let
random
bots or
people on twitter bother you that much
that's that's my recommendation
i i would recommend you i you know the
first time i kind of experienced that it
was when i was on
i was on rogan for the first time
and
the youtube video came out
and i sat there with my oldest daughter
who is probably
maybe 14 or 15 at the time and
i sat there and read these
heinous comments about me and laughed
but i mean
it was kind of you know some were pretty
good it was kind of funny so
yeah i'm not i i'm not getting bothered
by
somebody that wants to talk smack about
me for whatever
on twitter and also there's there's
probably some truth to whatever they're
saying you know they say i'm a big
knuckle dragger yeah probably right
you know
they say i'm an idiot yeah there's
definitely some of that what else
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace